[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time to see them what's
making the headlines with the associate
editors of the daily mirror and the
telegraph kevin mcguire and camilla
tommeny welcome to both of you so as
ever let's check out the front pages
shall we the financial times leading
with the health secretary's warning that
england could face a return to
coronavirus restrictions if the public
don't take steps to stay safe that is
also the lead story for the guardian
which quotes sajid javid as saying mps
should lead by example and wear masks in
crowded places
the telegraph quotes mr javid and its
headline have your booster jab to keep
your freedoms
same story for the metro call to arms
the eye also featuring those calls too
in order to save christmas this time it
says get the booster jab
the daily express reports the government
striking a deal with two leading
pharmaceutical firms to provide
anti-viral drugs
the daily mail says the new antivirals
will halve the risk of death from kovid
and the daily star has a story about
strictly come dancing contestant tilly
ramsay responding to a radio dj's
comments about her appearance
sir kevin mcguire and camila tommeny are
here now uh so news conference tonight
it's been a long time hasn't it
certainly things are challenging kevin
but not challenging enough
no five weeks i think since the the last
one and the government's taken it's a
foot off the gas on code it was almost
as if boris johnson wanted to ignore it
pretended had it had gone away so he
could
focus on good news and do his boosterism
but
the health secretary sachi javid as you
just said he repeated his warning that
there could be up to a hundred thousand
new infections every day and while he
wouldn't implement uh plan b said that
wasn't the plan at the moment he
effectively called on the population uh
to actually follow it in terms of
wearing masks in crowded nails places be
outdoors where you
can so he he was asking people to take
responsibility rather than taking
responsibility himself for enforcing uh
measures but the the stats at the stats
are grim and it and they're creeping up
uh combine that with the worries there
will be winter flu this year because
we're mixing and one expert said there
could be 60 000 deaths from that
possibly it could be more flu deaths and
covert deaths this winter but you can
you can see the the health secretary is
now getting a little bit concerned and
possibly close to panicking yes the
financial times then camilla act now or
expect to return to covid kerbs this
winter with the graph uh behind them uh
in the photograph there of jenny harry's
and uh the health secretary showing that
the rise um
upwards uh but as as kevin said um act
now in what way what what does he mean
by that is it just get the booster just
get a vaccine if you're 12 to 15 because
the the rest of it they've left to us
thereby absolving the government it
seems of any responsibility
it's an interesting exercise and
devolution this isn't it anna this idea
that it's for us to act now well i think
what the public will be asking first of
all is why hasn't the booster rollout
been more successful telegraph reported
today that only 27.8 of care home
residents and only eight fourteen
percent of staff had had their third jab
so again we're getting more coverage of
the fact that this booster rollout has
slowed second of all you'll have parents
questioning why children weren't
vaccinated sooner as they were in europe
i mean i've experienced first-hand as a
mum of three with three children off
with covert at one point or another
since october the fifth that it is
ripping through secondary schools now if
you're looking at just cases and those
case numbers aren't translating into
hospitalizations and deaths and
obviously
we could get to a hundred thousand if it
doesn't put more pressure on the nhs but
i suppose what health chiefs have been
warning today is the double or treble
whammy of that combined with as kevin
said flew and then the seasonal
pressures that the nhs faces anyway i
mean we had quasi quatta i'm talking
about hoping for a mild winter um but i
think from the public's point of view
it's really difficult to put this genie
back in the bottle kevin and i both were
at the labour party conference in
brighton the tory party conference in
manchester
mixing with hundreds of people without
masks i mean and that was by both
parties say so so to now mandate masks
ahead of boosters surely the most
effective
barrier to a resurgence of kovid is the
third jab
yeah well indeed so but it i mean it's
once again putting all your eggs in the
vaccine basket isn't it the you know the
other measures of mask wearing how do
you get people to start re-wearing them
um you know other parts of the uk never
never told people to take them off uh
kevin guardian uh javid warns of a
hundred thousand daily cases urges mps
to lead by example well they haven't
been have they sat on the benches not
wearing them for as long as we can
remember
no that's absolutely right i know the ft
say the
plan b won't be implemented before cop
26 at the beginning of next month well
that is in glasgow in scotland where you
need to wear a mask in indoors i think
public transport still and vaccine
passports are required to go into
nightclubs and big events but the the
guardian is picking up that he he was
questioned sashi javid you're telling
the public to wear masks might be very
uh sensible to do so but you and
ministers uh and many mps in the house
of commons and you and you look at those
pictures on tv there's no masks in the
chamber certainly on the conservative
side you'll see one or two dotted around
there are a lot more people wearing
masks on the on the opposition side
label lib dems smp and so on but amongst
the uh amongst the government side no
masks or very very few masks and he and
he conceded that was a problem so i
wonder if next time we see saji javad in
the house of commons in the chamber he
will be wearing a mask himself because i
think most most of us uh you you fall
you follow your leaders you also want to
know what the law is so when people are
making a choice should i wear a mask or
should i not wear a mask if you know a
mask is required most people
will wear it okay you'll get the uh
they'll get the anti-vaxxers who are
trying to kill satire as well as people
who will refuse to do so and some people
will forget it or be def if i can't
bother but most people comply with
regulations and laws but if mps aren't
wearing them i think people are less
likely to wear them themselves yes i
mean he does specifically say as well
especially when you're with people you
don't know so that that's public
transport really isn't it uh where as we
know many people have stopped wearing
mosques then as well um daily telegraph
have your booster jab to keep your
freedoms these long one freedoms and the
eye as well camilla raising the prospect
of christmas here we go here we go again
trying to save christmas
i know it's like deja vu isn't it um
interestingly we had a telegraph live
event today where i interviewed kate
bingham the former um uk government's
faxing czar and she was talking about
the urgency with which the government
should be pushing the boosters but also
antivirals and i know that's on one of
the front pages of the other papers
um
i mean again this
i don't know why it always has to come
down to christmas i mean we do seem to
be facing this sort of perfect storm of
turkey shortages combined with threat of
the return of some of these measures and
combined with everything else that's
going on a cost of living squeeze which
doesn't bode particularly well for the
festive period um
whether it's useful to be speculating
this far ahead remains to be seen but of
course the government's going to come in
for a lot of heavy criticism if it looks
like it's acting too slowly again i note
that leila moran is chair of the
coronavirus appg has been on the
airwaves tonight talking about a bit
more of a rapid response but clearly
javid wants to stall for a while i think
knowing that it's going to be deeply
unpopular it's interesting to look at
the regional picture as well because um
i think kevin mentioned there you know
mask wearing in scotland for cop 26
which is more vociferous than it is down
here at the moment it seems that in
england we've got about one case per 80.
um in scotland in wales they're not
doing quite as well they've got one per
30 45. scotland's a bit better than us
northern ireland's doing very well
indeed so by comparison so again are we
then going to get back into this other
case of deja vu of like the different
regions implying employing different
policies and then there being some
bickering between the different leaders
over the way ahead remember when
sturgeon kept on preempting the
government and making decisions ahead of
england
absolutely yes um but then you get
elements like morocco which has banned
flights to the uk and uh
you you know you know the le monde the
the newspaper in france is starting to
call us plague island um and we we heard
from our economics and data editor in
sconies at 10 suggesting actually that
part of it is that we are testing more
and specifically testing younger people
with the lateral flow tests and
secondary schools which then reveals
those who are asymptomatic who would not
necessarily get tested in in other
countries nonetheless though you know we
are running these enormously high cases
and actually tony blair who's speaking
once again in the eye uh ministers
should set a new target of 500 000
booster shots a day to avoid a fourth
lockdown and focus mines well it's well
short of that at the moment isn't it
kevin
oh no absolutely the
we got ahead on jabs uh but now we're
behind for double vaccinations behind uh
we're behind
several countries i think we're behind
spain i think we're behind italy i think
we're behind france we had an advantage
and it's gone it's gone away it's being
allowed to wither and there's big
criticism of the closure of pop up
centers center weather being open
there's been pictures of empty empty
seats people haven't heard about jobs
being available so that system isn't
working now there aren't the volunteers
you got last time around because people
feel exhausted and somewhat used it's
got to be said now the only the only
upside of uh cancelling christmas again
or squeezing uh christmas is the the
turkey and toy shortages won't be
noticed as much if people aren't buying
them but it is it is something of a mess
now and boris johnson is just determined
to again just put on that brave face
everything will be well dewey's
boosterism act but sometimes that can be
complacent in incompetence and we saw
the report from the two committees of
mps both chaired by conservatives former
cabinet ministers both with
conservatories that people died because
there wasn't action last time
kevin camilla stay there both of you
lots more still to come including uh her
majesty a royal period of rest
prescribed for the queen after the
monarch's marathon series of events more
on that in just a moment
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now kevin mcguire
and camilla thomanny and camilla
certainly the security of mps has been
to the fore after sir david amos pretty
patel in the comments this evening
raising the threat level for mps and the
pictures of michael gove being taunted
by protesters this week too
yeah i think worrying for michael gove
after everything that's happened and
there is a generally a sort of fearful
atmosphere i think in the commons i met
with a few mps this evening because
there was a women women's lobby event
and
of course people are reflecting on the
horrific tragedy that befell to david
but also there were discussions about
online hate just the general attitude of
the public towards mps i think jess
phillips the labour mp for birmingham
yardley said at the weekend you know
that the public considered them lower
than human and i think if that's the
case something's gone very very wrong
with our political discourse so to see
somebody like michael go sort of like
almost roughed up a rough up a bit on
the way to work it's not something that
anybody wants to see um
and i suppose pretty patel's statement
tonight although depressing is an
inevitable consequence of everything
that's happened i mean two mps to have
been killed in this way in five years um
is really a pretty sorry state of
affairs yeah and and a strange mood
around westminster because of this and
the reflections kevin of mps i mean and
commemorating today james brokenshire as
well who also passed away during the uh
the recess
he did the former northern ireland
security minister under the conservative
and actually he was uh he was he was a
sharp incredibly likable
guy but there have been mobs marauding
around parliament certainly since uh the
the brexit debate and now it's
anti-vaxxers some of them erected a
scaffold today which you think what goes
on then in their heads when an mp was
murdered the other day and they put up a
scaffold and the people michael gove was
it was mobbed by the times they're
reporting one of them's a former tory
councillor who was suspended from the
party for a racist remark and sat as an
independent but didn't attend meetings
in the council enfield for six months
and then was uh was booted off as a as a
result but as well as being covidius and
they aren't just genuine cove idiots
they're killing the satire there was a
mob that went into colchester
hospital to present what they claimed
were legal forms citing nuremberg and
the pope among the reasons for why uh
the pandemic was some great scam and the
staff couldn't hide as they put it
behind the nhs these people are
they raged from the just disturbed to
the really seriously uh dangerous
threats kevin we're running out of time
i did want to show people uh the picture
of her majesty the queen in the metro uh
super woman i think actually taking some
rest as well uh camilla and kevin thank
you both very much indeed we will see
you soon thank you